tech IPOs have dried up and that could
spell trouble for the whole industry
just one tech company has gone public in
the u.s. so far this year
it's practically unprecedented the
fewest tech IPOs we've ever had in a
single year was six in 2008 during the
financial crisis if this year keeps
going as it has been we could set a new
record people in Silicon Valley are
starting to worry about the drop-off and
tech ideas and here's why investors that
bet on young companies rely on IPOs to
make their money back they can't do that
they may stop writing checks to fund the
next Google or Facebook this is
happening already the amount of money
invested in startups has fallen from a
peak about six months ago so why are we
in this IPO desert for one about half
the tech companies that went public in
the US since 2010 are trading below
their IPO price just look at Twitter or
GoPro it's hard to sell investors on new
stocks when too many of them got burned
betting on the last IPOs and - there's a
big expectation skin there are more than
150 unicorns that's Silicon Valley
jargon for a start-up valued at a
billion dollars or more many of these
companies would be worth far less if
they tried to go public now so many of
them are waiting and waiting to try to
improve their business an IPO at a
higher price these unicorns could be
right to wait or they could run out of
money waiting for the perfect time to go
public